in case you hadn't figured it out
already the satanic Biden Administration
is Waging War on Christians the latest
escalation in this war came on Friday
morning when according to life site news
a SWAT team of 25 to 30 Jack booted FBI
agents in 15 Vehicles swarmed the home
of Mark Houck and his wife and their
seven children and raided the house with
rifles drawn and pointed at the family
Mark's crime
he's a pro-life author and sidewalk
counselor who gives his time to
peacefully demonstrate outside of
abortion Mills and let women know that
they don't need to kill their children
for this the Biden Administration
decided to traumatize his family and
arrest him at gunpoint
according to Mark's wife quote the kids
were all just screaming it was all just
very scary and traumatic as they
attempted to drag her husband off and
throw him into a police car she asked to
see a warrant at which point she says
quote they said that they were going to
take him whether they had a warrant or
not finally they relented and showed her
the first page of the warrant which
alleged that Mark had violated the
freedom of access to Clinic entrances
Act now according to Mark's wife this
charge had already been considered and
thrown out by a federal district court
but the Biden Administration doesn't
care about any of that the Biden
Administration has been accelerating its
attacks in recent months on
conservatives and Christians and
especially pro-life advocates
as the feds terrorized the hougs and
their children Mark tried to keep
everyone calm and simply requested that
his wife bring him a sweatshirt and his
rosaries by the time she got back to
hand them to him the feds had already
thrown him into one of their cars and
hauled him off to jail
lest anyone misunderstand and think that
I am using the word satanic here
hyperbolically or for mere rhetorical
effect I'm not I'm using the word
literally not only is the Biden
Administration doing satanic things such
as slaughtering babies castrating kids
and persecuting Christians
it also comprises actual overt satanists
who proudly wear pentagrams actual
satanic imagery on their bodies this is
as explicitly evil as it gets
and I consider these FBI agents
personally morally culpable for this
I know that there are good people who
work for the FBI and who do good work so
I constantly seek to distinguish between
the corrupt political leadership at the
FBI and the doj and the agents who are
just following orders
this is different
this is a direct participation in clear
evil these FBI agents the guys on the
ground
should not have followed this order they
should have sooner resigned before they
followed this evil order they should
feel deep shame for what they did the
agents they should beg forgiveness of
the Hauck family and of God and they
should resign their posts immediately
this is no mere quibble between the
political left and right
as Ronald Reagan observed
ultimately there is no such thing as
left or right only up or down and as Joe
Biden has consistently said we are in a
battle for the soul of America and in
that battle there can be no neutral
ground it is clear as day which side the
Biden Administration has picked those
who continue to support and follow these
kinds of evil orders have picked aside
too and now we all face an unavoidable
question
which side are you on I'm Michael
Knowles this the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
my favorite comment on Fridays from
Ralph Cole who says Michael now that Ben
is transitioning into a beard boy are
you considering doing the right thing as
well thanks love the show I am not
because Ben is transitioning into a
beard boy
because
we've sold all the Jeremy's razors this
is the problem we have all these
Jeremy's razors we thought there's no
way we can sell this many tens of
thousands of Germans raises well we have
they're very very popular because people
don't want to shop from companies like
Harry's that hate all of us so we've
sold all the razors now there are no
razors left for Ben fortunately I still
have some of my Jeremy's razors so I can
continue to shave and look nice and
cleanly shaven but Ben no he's going to
end up looking like a vagabond and
that's just going to persist until we
can manufacture more of this beautiful
beautiful blades you know when when I
think about the sort of medals that I
want to not only manufacture but that I
want to invest in that I want to keep
near me top of the list even before the
razors
Birch gold right now text Knowles to
989898 with the Consumer Price Index
increasing yet again the stock market
has been in absolute turmoil what is the
current Administration doing to quell
this surge of inflation
spending more taxpayer dollars do not
bury your head in the sand while your
savings deplete diversify into gold with
Birch gold today text Knowles Canada
wles to 98 98 98 and Birch gold will
send you a free info kit on protecting
your savings with gold in a tax
sheltered account the experts over at
Birch gold have almost 20 years of
experience in converting IRAs and 401ks
into precious metals IRAs with an A plus
rating from the Better Business Bureau
countless five star reviews and
thousands of satisfied customers why
have you not checked them out yet gold
has always been your best hedge against
inflation a diversified savings can
protect you from downturns in the market
head on over right now and text Knowles
Canada wles 298 9898 and Birch gold will
send you a free info kit on diversifying
into gold tax-free take the necessary
steps to hedge against inflation today
protect your hard-earned money get your
free info kit by texting Knolls Canon
w-l-e-s to 98 98 98 . I think it's good
that conservatives generally try to
distinguish between you know the corrupt
FBI political officials
and the good FBI agents I know FBI
agents there are lots of great FBI
agents who have done a lot of good work
at a certain point though you can't just
say well I was following orders well I
was following orders yeah I went I
showed up with guns drawn and terrorized
this pro-life author's family because he
had the audacity to peacefully gently
suggest that we shouldn't slaughter
babies I was just following orders no
you yet you were following orders but
you made a moral decision here and I
hold these agents personally responsible
and they should come out and they should
apologize and they should quit their
jobs but but you know they're close to
retirement I don't care I don't care you
know you know what what is it what is it
profit a man to gain his more of his
pension but to lose his soul that's what
these agents are doing these agents who
follow these evil orders are giving up
their souls they're making a deal with
the devil and it's not worth it and and
the FBI agents know it too there was a
great interview I'd encourage you to
check it out between an FBI
whistleblower and Dan bongino
the FBI whistleblower who's who's
talking about what these agents are
saying on the ground usually not to the
Press he says the number of guys who say
I don't agree with what's going on here
but I've got three years to retire it's
heartbreaking if anybody refuses to get
with the program
it's gonna it's brutal you know okay and
he and this agent actually is saying
many of the same things that we're all
talking about here saying I'm just
following orders the Nuremberg piece it
doesn't fly we know better we're
supposed to know that if they ask you to
do something that's illegal immoral or
unethical following orders is not an
excuse that's when you become part of
political Hatchet jobs I didn't sign up
for that nobody I know signed up for
that either that is not what people want
to get involved in and he says there's
more
people than you think who are coming
forward and there are many who have
already left the bureau and yes it's
true people want to get their pensions I
get it this stuff is just so
freaking evil could you imagine that
could you sign up you join the FBI you
want to be the good guys you want to
punish the bad guys and then what ends
up happening you you bust into some poor
pro-life authors home terrorize his wife
and seven kids guns drawn because he has
the audacity to say don't don't kill
kids maybe maybe we shouldn't knock we
should not kill all these kids
that's that's what you're fighting for
that's what you're holding that gun for
is to not to point the gun at the bad
guys it's to point the gun at the
pro-life authors and there's seven kids
don't do it it's not worth it speaking
of attacks on children and distrust of
our political leaders did you catch this
ad
that New York Presbyterian Hospital put
out this
this ad on the one hand
on the one hand it gave me the the
slight satisfaction
that we were entirely right
it gave me the satisfaction if I told
you so it gave me the satisfaction of
I'm Nostradamus and I predict the future
but it irritated me so much because of
the gaslighting campaign going on from
the libs right now specifically with
regard
to myocarditis take a listen
since I can remember
said it was actually my heart it was
severely swollen something called
myocarditis but doctors gave me
medicines and used machines to control
my heartbeat they'd saved me so now I
can become the next great fashion
designer
maybe my memory is a little foggy
I don't remember ever seeing an
advertisement
for treating
myocarditis in children before have you
ever seen that did you ever hear about
that an epidemic of myocarditis the
swelling of the heart in kids I don't
remember that
in fact the first time I even heard that
word was when I heard it mentioned as a
side effect of the covet vaccine
and at the time some people were
reporting on this side effect where
especially in young people their hearts
would get really enlarged if they took
the covet vaccine and at the time it was
reported as a rare side effect
well initially they tried to deny it but
then the libs had to admit it even the
CDC admits that uh yes myocardite is the
swelling of the heart is a side effect
of the coveted vaccines the MRNA ones
specifically in young people but it's a
really rare side effect
it's so rare
that New York Presbyterian Hospital
is airing a very highly produced
expensive advertisements
selling treatment for this rare side
effect in kids
it's kind of weird isn't it would you
would you spend a lot of money
producing and airing a commercial to
sell a treatment for something that
barely ever happened I don't think I
would
I don't think I would do that we were
totally right
we were totally right the conservatives
when we said hey
covid's not that bad for kids generally
speaking hey there seemed to be some
side effects for these vaccines hey if
people have actually some people have
actually died from the vaccines hey if
you're not at a great risk from the
virus then probably it doesn't make a
ton of sense to take this new
experimental drug when we said that we
were all censored we were ostracized we
were called science deniers we were
called killers
we said there might be any side effects
at all and specifically for young people
and then what happened
they admit that we're right
they implicitly admit that that we're
right but at the same time they continue
to censor us
for saying the same thing the same
things that they do they say the things
they say look yeah this might cause
myocarditis you know okay and here's
some treatment for it okay that's
wonderful we've got these treatments
thank you New York Presbyterian now I'm
going to go be the best best that I can
be but then the minute the conservatives
say the same thing hey this thing is
causing myocarditis in kids what they
say you're a crazy conspiracy theorist
Gene to be kicked off of the internet
there is some good news on the
censorship front there is some pushback
now in the censorship front so there's a
Texas law
that prohibits large social media
companies from Banning users posts based
on their political viewpoint
uh this uh law was blocked
by a court and now a federal appeals
court Has Lifted the block that was
placed on the statute this is known as
House Bill 20 was passed last year it
argued that internet companies have a
First Amendment right to curate uh their
content oh so I'm sorry the law said
that the the internet companies do not
have a First Amendment right to curate
their content the companies then came
back and said no we do the first
amendment applies to us and we ought to
be able to decide what goes on our
platforms uh so the fifth Circuit Court
of Appeals says today we reject the idea
that corporations have a freewheeling
First Amendment right to censor what
people say of course
of course you have to
because
if the corporations have the right to
censor what is in the Public Square then
we lose our political power
because we the people in self-government
have to be able to speak and debate
issues in the Public Square
and I don't care if it's if it's the
government censoring me I don't care if
it's the corporations and the oligarchy
that owns the Public Square that's
censoring me if I'm being censored and I
can't say what I want to say in the
Public Square then it's exactly the same
thing
and this is a major shift that
conservatives have realized because 10
years ago 15 years ago we would be
Shilling for the very corporations that
are taking away our political rights
right now we'd say well you know if you
don't if you don't want to be censored
then build your own Google no I don't
think so I think I'm going to pass a law
and I'm going to wield the state to stop
Google from destroying my political
rights and traditions but
free market
yeah no that's not it's not a free
Marketplace and actually even in right
now the way that big Tech operates is
not in a free Marketplace at all there
are three big platforms that have gained
their market dominance largely through
fraud and by exploiting legal loopholes
but even beyond that even if it were a
free Marketplace of ideas someone has to
set the rules of a Marketplace that's
true and a little bizarre that's true in
a shopping mall and that's true and the
internet as well
we have the right to do that and now
we're going to do that and great great
on the appeals court for for
acknowledging this
now what's bizarre in this world of
left-wing censorship is that what is not
censored what is not banned
becomes mandatory there's a clip that's
resurfaced of the uh Senate candidate
the Democrat Senate nominee in
Pennsylvania John fetterman who was
dressed up in a bizarre rainbow cape and
hat looking
well pretty much as weird as he always
does but in a slightly different way
John Federman was interviewed last year
by some LGBT LMNOP activist on whether
or not he believes that LGBT education
grooming should be mandatory in schools
here's what he says now with the uh
especially education which is what our
Focus here at Power rainbows is uh would
you support the Department of Education
making it mandatory in all schools for
lgbtq education
I'm sorry I didn't hear the last part
would you make it uh would you be
supportive of legislation that makes it
mandatory for lgbtq education in our
schools for History Literature science
and so on I I I'm for as many
perspectives and and letting everybody
be included in because we're all part of
America and we all have history and that
should be a part of of American History
because you are a part of America in
these communities you know so
so he's trying to avoid giving a direct
answer to the question but but in trying
to avoid it he does give a direct answer
saying I want everything to be included
everything including
apparently LGBT education I don't know
what LGBT education is by the way
what does he mean do you think LGBT
education should be mandatory in schools
what teaching them how to do the stuff
teaching them what what is LGB LGBT
education
sounds like grooming to me I know that
word is being bandied about a lot but if
you're if you're teaching someone the
ins and outs as it were of LGBT then
isn't that grooming isn't that what the
conservatives are accusing the libs of
doing the libs are basically admitting
it right there
and of course John fetterman doesn't
want every perspective included he
doesn't think the Bible should be taught
in schools the most the the fundamental
text of Western Civilization I Promise
You John fetterman doesn't think that
should be taught in schools but gender
queer by Maya kababi should be LGBT
pornography like genderqueer I guess
that should be taught in schools that
should be mandatory the Bible that's got
to be banned speaking of LGBT activism
by the way
the most delightful hilarious clip of
the weekend comes by way of the LGBT
community and LGBT issues which is Joe
Biden
apparently blaming Elton John for AIDS
by the way
it's all his fault that we're spending
six billion dollars in taxpayer money
this month to help aides fight HIV AIDS
you could see Elton John there he's like
is what is this man
is he blaming me for AIDS and then
blaming me for spending taxpayer money
on AIDS and then and Biden finally
finishes Elton John's looking so puzzled
and then Elton John goes he has no idea
what he's saying I'll just smile and he
kind of gives a little smile and gives
gives some Applause I assume what Joe
Biden is trying to incinuate here is
that Elton John lobbied for this
government spending on AIDS
but the way it comes out is not that's
not how it sounds we got to blame this
guy this guy he man you know this guy
come on Jack you know this guy probably
him and Corn Pop went down to a few too
many bath houses now we got to spend a
gazillion dollars of your money on AIDS
come on give a round of applause for
Elton John it's like what
what the heck man that's that's that's
his homophobic
as it possibly gets
usually however
LGBT activism is not quite so funny that
was a very funny clip usually it's not
quite so funny there's a British girl
who has gone viral for describing an
experience that she had in the gender
neutral changing room which she says she
supports by the way because she's so
politically correct and liberal and
open-minded intolerant but despite all
the wonderful promises about how
gender-neutral bathrooms are going to
lead to Greater equality and flourishing
for everybody that's not what happened
so I was just in Primark
um in Cambridge
and um I've already stupid being
emotional about this but
um
yeah I was trying on some clothes and it
was a unisex changing room which I'm
really full and I love that because you
know it makes everyone feel included but
twice
um two men walked opened the curtain
walked in on me
um luckily both times I had I was
wearing fully clothes but I could easily
not have been
um and I yeah it was two different
people
um clearly from the same group and there
was Millie like probably like 100
changing rooms available
um so it's not like you know it was like
always someone in here or not it was you
know clearly
um yeah I just want to say to people
please be careful
um and if you go to the changing room
try not go on your own
um I will never be doing that again I
would rather take it home try it on and
then take it back and get refunded
this woman is never going to try on
clothing in a store again
because why
Why Can't This Woman do a really basic
thing involved in shopping for clothing
because men are now allowed to get naked
in the same rooms as women and that the
only men who are doing this by the way
are mentally ill men who think that they
are women and who have bizarre sexual
fetishes and desires and it turns out
that those mentally ill men with bizarre
sexual fetishes and desires sometimes
behave sexually inappropriately and pull
the curtain open on women as they change
who could have guessed wow stop the
presses we got a man bites dog story
here folks
no we don't of course this happened
and why are we even in the the position
in society where this can take place
where this woman could be victimized in
this way because we've indulged all
those completely insane premises and why
have we indulged those insane premises
because we were told by the the liberal
brainiacs that actually men and women
aren't different and even though they
seem different in every way even though
not in every way there are similarities
between men and women but even though by
all of our senses we can tell that there
do exist differences between men and
women and those differences are
significant
we have to deny that reality we have to
ignore reality because of their Egghead
Pie in the Sky ideology they're they're
wonderful utopian idea that men and
women are exactly the same
and if the reality doesn't match the
theory
it doesn't mean that the theory is wrong
it means that we have to deny reality
and so now we can't go shopping anymore
we can't go shopping
can't use the bathroom we can't we can't
you can't send your daughter into a
changing room at the public pool because
you know there's very possibly going to
be some creepy dude in there with some
bizarre sexual Hang-Ups waiting to prey
on them
so what do we do do we change the rules
do we tell the liberal Eggheads that
they were wrong
do we tell the men to stop putting
dresses on and to start dressing like
men and to start behaving
no no we just allow Society to crumble
and we lose all of our nice privileges
that we all enjoyed in our nice way of
life and we lose that because of a
theory that's preposterous
I mean I'm beginning to think we do we
need gender clinics you know on the
right we've been we've been now saying
that we need to get rid of all these
gender clinics certainly the Pediatric
gender clinics but the adult gender
clinics too you know where a man goes in
and he he gets a doctor to chop him up
and make him look more like a woman I
think we need gender clinics we need we
need many more gender clinics in America
here are the gender clinics
if you're a woman the gender Clinic is
they already exist but we need more it's
called The Beauty Salon
and for the man that what is the gender
Clinic the gender Clinic I don't know
it's a cigar bar it's a gymnasium it's I
don't it's these things already exist if
a woman goes in to the doctor says doc I
feel like a man I think I might be a man
you know and I want to dress like a man
and cut off my hair really short like a
man and even chop up my body the man is
going to say oh the doctor is going to
say okay ma'am I'm prescribing you one
trip to the female gender clinic and uh
I I'm going to prescribe you a mani pedi
and a nice hairdo and a little bit of
makeup and then you're gonna go there
and you're going to look more like a
woman and and probably feel more like a
woman and you are going to do your duty
and your responsibility if you're a
woman to behave like a woman and if
you're a man to behave like a man that's
the gender Clinic I want to I want a
federal law Congress get on it
speaking of
reactions against this kind of crazy
crazy stuff
the the greatest news right now
in international politics is coming out
of Italy and that would be the Italian
elections last night the Italians have
elected a conservative
government led by a woman named Georgia
Maloney
how do you know that Georgia Maloney is
great you know Georgia Maloney is great
because the Atlantic is calling her a
fascist you know that Georgia Maloney is
totally spot on the money because the
libs are losing their minds and they're
doing what they do anytime anybody to
the right of Hillary Clinton gets
elected anywhere they're saying this is
horrific it's Nazi it's fascist it's
racist it's this is it's thatist it's
undemocratic yes that's right more
people voted for this lady than voted
for the other people but and that's why
it's undemocratic because the people
voted for her well so what has she said
that's so fascist and Nazi and racist
and terrible here's what she said I will
translate for you a beautiful little
speech from Georgia Maloney
this is what we're doing today
because it defines us because it's our
identity
because everything that defines us is
now an enemy
for those who don't want us to have an
identity anymore and to be perfect
consumers
so they attack national identity
they attack religious identity they
attack General gender identity they
attack family identity
I'm not allowed to Define myself as
Italian
Christian woman mother genetics I've got
to be citizen X gender X parent one
parent two I've got to be enough
because when I'm only a number I don't
have an identity I don't have a Roots
I'll be the perfect slave
at the mercy of financial speculators
the perfect consumer spot on the
freaking money spot on the money and she
goes on later in that speech
I can't believe there's an Italian
politician quoting this man she goes on
to quote G.K Chesterton the Great
British conservative a hero to American
conservatives
a hero to Christians a hero to Christian
conservatives especially
she goes on to say no we're going to
defend our families we're going to
defend our way of life we're going to
defend our countries against the
predations of the Davos set the great
resetters the the people who want to
erase our borders erase our identity
erase our culture erase all the things
that we hold dear and and make us all
live in this clinical generic sexless
nationless familyless
dystopia where we're all living in ba in
pods and eating bugs we're not going to
do that
okay you know the conservative who's in
a coalition government with this lady
because you know the way the way
politics Works in Italy it's not like
there's just two parties and one wins
and one loses there are lots and lots of
different parties and so this government
that's going to be led by Georgia
Maloney has got other conservative
parties in it one of the leaders of one
of those conservative parties the Lego
party
this guy Matteo salvini who I love he's
just like a big happy Italian guy and
he'll tweet out pictures of spaghetti
bowls of spaghetti I've actually seen
this pop up in my Twitter feed and I
love that he does that this is the kind
of appeal that people want to see in
politics and that people ought to make
in politics
I don't want my politicians to give me
some stupid Egghead spreadsheet
five-point plan of some utopian abstract
technocrat nonsense I want politicians
to realize that what do I really what do
I really want from my politicians I want
them to protect my bowl of spaghetti I
want them to protect my way of life my
traditions my culture my family and my
community okay and I don't want some pie
in the sky plan on how we're going to
upend everything and innovate everything
and get rid of borders and we're all
going to sing Kumbaya as citizens of the
world no protect my spaghetti protect my
family this woman Georgia Maloney she
says we've got a simple mandate here
okay we are we are running for God for
family and for country
okay those are the important things to
us not for Davos not for global warming
not not for socialism not for any of
this crap okay we're running for God
for family and for Country beautiful I
want you know I say I don't make
endorsements in the primary elections in
America as of right now before we've got
any declared candidates for president of
the United States in 2024. Georgia
Maloney has my support right now if we
can figure out a way
to make Georgia Maloney a citizen of
America and to amend the Constitution so
that you don't need to be a natural-born
citizen I
I'm so inclined to support this woman
for president whoever the Republican
nominee is in 2024 I want you to read
her speeches verbatim okay
she's great
if you look on Wikipedia right now
Wikipedia says that she's a far right
hard right candidate and why
I don't have the text in front of me but
you can go look it up on your own I've
roughly what it says is because she she
opposes abortion
she opposes euthanasia that is assisted
suicide
she supports National borders she poses
illegal immigration
and and she opposes same-sex marriage I
kid you not that's one of the main
issues that Wikipedia cites as to why
this woman is far right hard right
insinuating that she's a fascist
because this woman holds the view of
marriage
that Barack Obama held in 2011. that's
now considered hard right far right the
view of marriage that every single
person on planet Earth held for all of
human history until roughly 2015.
the view of marriage that Barack Obama
one of our most left-wing presidents
that we've ever had held as recently as
11 years ago
now if you hold that position you are
considered hard right far right fascist
nazi and so those words mean nothing
Nazi doesn't mean Nazi when the libs use
it fascist doesn't mean fascist when the
libs use it in fact when I see those
words hurled at conservative politicians
by the dishonest left-wing media I just
assume it's a great politician
because I know the one thing I know for
sure is when the libs call you a Nazi or
a fascist you're you're for sure not a
Nazi or fascist so what is it just means
that you have any kind of inkling toward
a serious type of conservatism not the
squishy lame fake Liz Cheney
kind of conservatism you know just maybe
cut taxes and bomb the Middle East kind
of conservatism no no deep conservatism
support my family support my country
support my traditions support National
borders real conservatism you know in a
world of Liz Cheney's be a Georgia
Maloney so now what what are the libs
going to do about it
because they don't like that this lady
just got elected in Italy what are they
going to do they see this as part of a
broader Trend in the world a right-wing
government being elected in Poland a
right-wing government being elected in
Hungary a right-wing government being
elected in America with Donald Trump
although they figured out how to get rid
of him at least for the time being
so what are they going to do about this
well the president of the European
commission says
they've got backup plans
we'll see
if things go in a difficult direction
I've spoken about Hungary and
Poland we have tools if things go in the
right direction
and people as a body that is always
where always governments have to be
accountable to play an important role
we've got tools we in Brussels we in the
European commission we in the EU we we
have tools to deal with it if those
Italians get a little too rowdy you know
and they elect someone that we don't
like
because you see what the election of
Georgia Maloney represents is an attack
on democracy
this is what they this is what they all
say
when those hungarians elected Victor
Orban that's an attack on democracy
when those polls elected a right-wing
government that's an attack on Democracy
okay they can't be an attack on
democracy
by definition
people electing someone and then that
person taking power is a Triumph of
democracy
but when the libs talk about democracy
they're not talking about democracy
they're talking about liberalism
and I know some people on the right want
to make all these distinctions well it's
not really liberalism we're the true
liberals and they're the real whatever
okay liberalism progressivism leftism
whatever you want to call it
I just call them the libs generally I
think that's simple it gets the message
across but but what they mean is their
preferred ideology they would support
the imposition of their preferred
liberal ideology
even if 99 of the people voted against
it
they would say that if 99 of the people
voted for a conservative government and
then they imposed liberalism on those
people who don't want it that still that
would be a Triumph of democracy
because so they don't really mean
democracy right
they mean liberalism which they're going
to impose top down even against the will
of the people
which brings up a great point that the
conservative uh law professor at Harvard
Adrian vermeul continues to make
which is that liberalism is not so open
and tolerant and liberalism doesn't
usually doesn't necessarily and doesn't
even usually reflect the will of the
people liberalism is coercive very often
you'll see sometimes squishy American
conservatives say this to say look we
don't love liberalism but if you get rid
of liberalism
gosh if you have an illiberal
authoritarian government why that would
be coercive
would it be as coercive as liberalism I
doubt that liberalism is coercive the
majority of people don't want open
borders the majority of Americans forget
Italy for a second the majority of
Americans want to drastically reduce all
immigration legal and illegal
that according to a Harvard Harris poll
and yet it never happens why liberalism
won't allow it the majority of Americans
are considerably pro-life and yet we've
got one of the most radical pro-abortion
regimes in the world much more radical
than well pretty much anyone other than
China North Korea and Canada
why why is that why why is the will of
the American people not being reflected
in abortion policy because liberalism
won't let that happen when when marriage
was radically redefined by the Supreme
Court the vast majority of Americans
opposed that definition of marriage they
supported the traditional definition of
marriage which we had everywhere it was
that the new definition of marriage the
same sex marriage quote unquote was
imposed by five lawyers on the Supreme
Court
really by Anthony Kennedy trying his
hand at romantic poetry in the
obergefield decision
that's not reflecting the will of the
people that's a radical coercion and
imposition from liberalism
and it's why it's why I don't use that
talk a kind of harangues against
illiberalism or authoritarianism I just
I don't even think the words really mean
very much at all yes political movements
very often are driven by minorities
that's true virtually everywhere and
political movements are intrinsically
coercive and the liberalism as far as I
can tell is pretty much as coercive as
it gets you know sometimes it feels as
though the the left is coming at us from
every angle and we are just one mean
tweet away from being canceled for good
take heart everybody free speech is
alive and well here at the daily wire
because
when I and my cohorts hold our
all-access lives behind the paywall no
one can stop us I am extremely excited
to let you know that Jordan Peterson
who's recently come into our fold will
be hosting his very first all-access
live tomorrow September 27th at 1 pm
Eastern that is right a q a with the
great public intellectual Jordan
Peterson Jordan's all access is
exclusively for daily wire plus all
access members so if you are not a
member yet go to dailywire.com Knowles
to subscribe today
the liberal stuff is not popular and
it's not just that it's not popular in
the red States and in the conservative
parts of the country and countries it's
not popular frequently even in the
liberal places Nancy Pelosi was just
booed
at a music festival in New York City
this is the global citizen Festival in
New York City you would imagine that
these people are overwhelmingly Libs and
then there's Nancy Pelosi up there
speaking and she's getting booed and
it's funny you hear that one guy in the
back goes why is everybody booing
I don't know the clip that's gone viral
actually doesn't give a ton of context
into specifically what Nancy Pelosi is
talking about but here's why she might
be being booed
because everything that the Democrats
have touched has turned to Ash the
economy foreign policy education
immigration
and everything in the middle it's all
Fallen apart this is why the Democrats
are underwater on every single public
policy issue this is why the Democrats
are running way way behind when you look
at the polls for the midterm elections
so I'm frankly I'm not really surprised
that Nancy Pelosi is getting booed in
New York City
New Yorkers especially the ones that are
kind of you know in the the rich parts
of town who go to all the fancy liberal
soirees they can be taken with liberal
Flights of Fancy but they they don't
like getting mugged
they don't like dirty streets
they don't like bums and criminals
running around everywhere
they don't like when the economy is
tanking
they don't like stupid foreign policy
that's causing huge disruptions to the
energy industry and to the stock market
and to end everything they don't like
bad government okay
and so how are the Democrats going to
win in this kind of an environment the
only thing they can do
is threaten violence
this is this is why to get back to the
very top of the show this is why Joe
Biden is sicking his thugs his Jack
booted thugs on ordinary nice polite
pro-life activists this is why Joe Biden
is hiring 87 000 IRS agents and giving
some of them guns to go after you
this is why Joe Biden is letting his
criminals off the hook the BLM criminals
and the antifa criminals he's letting
them off the hook he's encouraging them
to terrorize you
and why he is throwing you in prison
it's why he's taking the the midwestern
grandmothers who show up to the capital
Rotunda and get a little excitable on
January 6th he's throwing them in
solitary confinement but he's letting
the BLM Thugs who kill people off the
hook
because the only way
that an unpopular liberal agenda can
maintain its political power
is through coercion and through force
and through the threat of violence and
sometimes explicitly through violence
there's a story that is not being
covered anywhere in the mainstream media
it's only being covered on on some
conservative Outlets this would be the
story of a 40-something-year-old liberal
who just murdered an 18 year old
conservative
for being a conservative
so they got into some political
disagreement at a bar
and then this older liberal guy runs
over the conservative kid
just for being a Republican and he said
he's a republican extremist that's why I
did it using the same kind of language
that Joe Biden is using when he calls
the rest of us semi-fascists and extreme
threats to our democracy
and then
then the cherry on top of this truly
hideous sort of political Sunday the
situation that we find ourselves in is
that this man Shannon Brandt the
murderer comes out and he complains that
now he might have to sit in jail for a
long time
I don't understand the differences 41
year old Shannon Brandt had a tough time
understanding the charges against him
vehicular homicide and leaving the scene
of a deadly accident a judge ordered
Brant held on fifty thousand dollars
cash what she objected saying he's not a
Flight Risk
by a life and a house and things that I
don't exactly want to see
you know go by the wayside
family that are very important to me
he's got a family he's got a job he's
got a house he doesn't want to see that
go by the wayside
by the way he's not even he's not even
being held without bond it's not even
that the judge is saying look you
murdered a kid because he was
conservative it was a complete political
motivation and so I'm just going to hold
you in jail until your trial
wasn't that he said okay I'm going to
let you out of jail
50 000 Bond
it's not even that high
considering the crime it's not even that
high and he says what I gotta come up
with 50 G's come on man I gotta get back
to work
that's not how it's supposed to work in
this country I'm a Democrat I'm supposed
to be able to do whatever I want
that's what the George Floyd people did
that's what all the BLM Riders they went
out and they killed people and they
burned buildings down and they attacked
Federal courthouses and they robbed and
they looted they didn't get in trouble
why am I getting in trouble yeah if I
were a republican I could see why I'd be
held in jail I'd be held in solitary
confinement for months
but I'm not I'm a Democrat you're going
to make me Pony up 50 G's
it's amazing I'm I'm positive some
left-wing group will bail him out if
they haven't bailed him out already they
probably have
that's what the the shock is the most
defensive part
because he because he knows this guy
Shannon Brandt knows what we all know
which is that the Democrats have
different rules and that the Democrats
are permitted to commit political
violence and that the Democrats are
encouraged to commit political violence
and that Maxine Waters Eric Holder and
Hillary Clinton and all the rest of them
and to say nothing of the pundits or
saying you go out there don't be civil
with Republicans get up in their face
push back on them go to their homes
where their children sleep and then what
happens a liberal from California goes
to Brett Kavanaugh's house and tries to
murder the Kavanaugh family
certainly at least to assassinate
Justice Kavanaugh
that's what happens
why because why was he even allowed to
get close to the guy's house well
because the the libs had been permitted
to illegally protest outside of the
justices houses no consequences
whatsoever
with the with the encouragement of the
White House actually they said well we
have no position on where people protest
wink wink maybe you shouldn't overrule
Roe v Wade guys because we're going to
send our thugs to go threaten you and
maybe kill you
that's what you get
speaking of attacks
about four five years ago
there were a Spate of attacks on
conservatives at college campuses and I
know this very well because I was the
subject of one of those attacks but it
wasn't just me I was attacked by some
Looney Tune with a super soaker full of
who knows what kind of liquids at uh
University of Missouri Kansas City but
you saw attempted attacks on
Ben you know on on Ben Shapiro at
different schools you saw tax on Ann
Coulter you saw a tax on people all
around the gun
there were so many um the names even
escaped me at this point there was one
on I think Charles Murray they went
after him
uh Andy no obviously anyway there are
lots and lots of attacks and then it
kind of calmed down for a little bit I
think the libs figured out that
attacking people at the college campuses
had diminishing marginal returns so they
stopped doing it now I guess it's back
because Tommy Lauren was just attacked
at a University of New Mexico event
the school said that protesters
vandalized University property
unlawfully pulled a firearm they were so
threatening and violent that I don't
think Tommy even appeared for the event
take a listen
they're trying to keep the door closed
because this screaming mob outside you
got cops and people in plain clothes
trying to keep the doors closed
these left-wing maniacs
F Tommy Lauren F Tommy Lauren
can't tell if that's even Tommy's
speaking
certainly the event was disrupted it's
TP USA event
and the reason I mention it
is because it's Tommy Lauren
Tommy Lauren is pretty liberal Tommy
Lauren would go on TV and defend
abortion and say that pro-lifers are
hypocrites
because because conservatives are
supposed to be for small government and
that means that we should be able to
kill babies too I mean she would say
these sorts of things I don't say it to
make fun of Tommy but just to point out
Tommy is not the most right-wing person
out there if any Tommy's sort of
I don't know I'd call her probably
Center left at the very most she's
center right
and the libs are doing this to her
she's too right-wing for them she this
essentially pro-abortion advocate
I don't know her position on same-sex
marriage I assume she's pretty liberal
on that
I just she's not when we talk about the
social conservative issues which is to
say actual conservatism you know not
just cutting taxes but like actual you
believe that you want to conserve
something about the political tradition
about Society This Woman's
at most Centrist
and they go after her just like they go
after everybody this is they're going to
call they call Tommy a fascist they call
Tommy a Neo-Nazi
they call all of us these names
okay and it's why it means absolutely
nothing you are about to hear
in Italy especially coming out of Italy
you're about to hear that this is the
return of Mussolini this is the return
of Hitler this is forget about Mussolini
it's Hitler it's it's Hitler it's Mega
Hitler it's this is the worst thing
that's ever happened get ready they're
gonna she's gonna invade check of
Slovakia or something like that okay and
it's all just completely nonsense it's
all completely made up
okay and they're going to ramp up those
attacks not just on Italian politicians
and not just on Tommy Lauren they're
going to ramp them up on you they're
going to ramp them up on quiet pro-life
activists they're going to ramp them up
on people who just want to follow their
faith and follow their culture and their
traditions and preserve their family
they're going to attack you that's why
they're beefing up the IRS that's why
they're sicking they're they're they're
dogs they're absolute Jack booted Thugs
and having them raid the political
opposition's home at Mar-A-Lago and
having them raid the pro-lifers house
and terrorize their kids okay and and
it's it's getting much more intense
we're only in 2022 okay we're not even
in 2024. things are heating up very very
quickly you want to make sure that you
don't get caught in a position where you
say well I was just going along to get
along well I was just following orders
there is no neutrality when we're
talking about issues of Stark good and
evil pick a side you know it's music
Monday and the producers they want to
mix it up a little bit okay
so they've given me a song that they say
is very very wholesome very very good
it's not WAP
it's not lizzo even though I kind of
like that lizzo song it's not it's
really
really good nice wholesome good American
content so we'll see it might be a
little too wholesome for me I'll get
we'll give a little bit of a read the
rest of the show is continuing now you
don't want to miss it if you're not a
member click the link in the description
and join us we'll see at the member
block
[Music]
[Music]